نحن هنا في هذا الملعب وسط مدينه عفرين
حيث هرع الاهالي هنا الى هذا الملعب بعد
حدوث الزلزال والهزه الارتداديه كما نشاهد
الاهالي يفترشون هذا الملعب في الارض جراء
هذا الزلزال وهناك مخاوف من استمرار
الهزات الارتداديه وسط عدم توفر خيام لهذه
العائلات لكي تبيت ليلتها فيها وذلك هم
اصلا كانوا من المتضررين جراء
الزلزالين والهزات الارتداديه منذ السادس
من هذا الشهر وما زالوا وما زالت المعاناه
مستمره من خلال نقص الخيام نقص نقص
الايواء ونقص التغذيه في هذا المكان اذا
هي حاله ماساويه يشهدها الشمال السوري
وذلك مع استمرار نقص المساعدات
وجاءت وجاء هذا الزلزال والهزات
الارتداديه هذا اليوم من المعاناه حيث
رصدنا هذا حاله هلع كبيره اعادتنا للحظات
الاولى للحدوث الزلزال الاول في السادس من
شباط الجاري
عمر حوراني الجزيره
من مدينه عفرين في حلب